just days after russia invaded ukraine
natalie prescott income and nick fel
fentoff fled their home in kiev and came
here to stay with nick's parents in the
city of eugene ukrainsk at the time they
thought it was the safest place they
could be because it's right next to a
nuclear power plant it was some thoughts
that
russians won't be so
i don't know crazy to take over the
power plant nick's father is an engineer
he and nearly half of the city's 40 000
residents work for the south ukraine
nuclear power plant
while many ukrainian cities have
witnessed mass evacuations yusuno
ukrainsk has seen people moving in this
volunteer helping to distribute aid just
arrived
i'm not afraid he says the russians
wouldn't risk shelling this city it's
too dangerous even for them
we met people from across ukraine who
have come to this city believing that it
might be one of the safest places in the
country right now during the war because
the russian military wouldn't dare to
attack a city with a nuclear plant but
then three weeks ago
it did
on march 4th russian forces shelled a
different nuclear plant europe's largest
sparking a fire and fueling fears of a
meltdown though the safety systems of
its six reactors were never affected
after russia's army seized control of
the plant it advanced towards another in
yusuno ukrainsk i remember i didn't
sleep i i
i was always checking and updating youth
after coming within 30 kilometers of
this city russian forces were eventually
pushed back and ukraine has since
retaken control of the larger plant a
close call and a wake-up call
at that point i knew that
you can expect anything from them i
don't know it's
scary the couple says everyone they know
is now stocking up on these potassium
iodide pills which protect against
radiation exposure they've also set up
mattresses in the halls away from the
windows but they're staying put
when it comes to a potential russian
attack or a nuclear emergency they say
nowhere is safe
some more safer but still it's like i
don't know russian roulette
jeff semple global news yujino krejinsk
ukraine